-Our first guest tonight
is an Emmy-
and Golden Globe-nominated actor
you know from shows
such as "Black-ish."
He stars in the 21st season
of "Law & Order,"
which premieres -- Wally?
You know what I'm going to say?
Yeah, how'd you spell
"twenty-first"?
Show everybody on the card.
"Twent."
[ Laughter ]
"Twent." You used
the old English spelling.
-Yeah.
-"'Twas the twent-first.
Oh, I remember it well.
Four days before Christmas,
it was."
[ Laughter ]
He stars --
He stars in the 21st season
of "Law & Order,"
which returns
February twent-fourth.
Oh, my God.
No, I know, you got that one
right, which is weird.
You would think it would be
the same on both.
[ Laughter ]
At 8:00 p.m. right here on NBC.
Let's take a look.
-Where were you last night,
10:00?
-At a bar in Red Hook
called Ray's.
Talking to the bodyguard,
trying to work things out.
-You make a deal?
-No, he offered me 50K.
Told him he can go to hell.
-Dumb move.
-Why is that?
-King's dead.
-For real, he gone?
-Somebody shot him.
-I needed that money, man.
-Well, unless he named you
in his will, you're out of luck.
-[ Chuckles ]
We'll be in touch.
-Please welcome back to the show
Anthony Anderson, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back!
-Thank you for having me back.
Now, before we get started --
-Yes.
-Before we get started...
-Okay.
-...you just saw in that clip
from the twent-first season
of "Law & Order"...
-Yeah.
-...my co-star Jeffrey Donovan.
-A great actor.
-Yeah.
-Massachusetts guy.
-Yeah, he doesn't think
you like him.
-What?
-Because he's been trying
to get on this show.
And you guys
keep telling him no.
-No, that's not true.
-You just said it.
-I said it's not true.
-Oh, okay.
I'm just letting you know.
-Okay.
-So I'm --
Jeffrey, you heard it.
He does like you, and he may not
need you on the show now
because I'm here,
but I put a plug in for you.
So hopefully you can
come on here.
-Now, of course,
I'd have to say it
the way I just said it, right?
-Yes.
-I mean, if I didn't like him,
I'm not going to admit it here.
-No, you're not.
-Right.
-No.
-So really, I think,
the proof will be whether or not
he's ever here.
-Only time will tell.
-Yeah.
-Okay.
-This is like a cliffhanger.
-It is.
It is.
-But I do.
I love Jeffrey Donovan.
He was fantastic -- He's been
fantastic in a million things.
But he was fantastic in "Fargo,"
fantastic in "Burn Notice."
And I'm so happy to see
the two of you together.
We were talking backstage, I'm
so happy "Law & Order" is back.
-No, so am I, man.
I didn't realize that people
really missed the mother ship.
-They do.
-Yeah, yeah,
the way that they did, man.
So, you know, people have been
stopping me on the street.
It was like, "I can't wait."
I was like, "Yeah,
season finale of 'Black-ish.'"
Go, "No, not that."
I was like, "What,
the season premiere
of 'To Tell the Truth'?"
"No, not that show."
"What, me hosting
the Image Awards?"
"No! 'Law & Order.'"
I was like, "Oh, I forgot."
-Yeah.
-I also cannot believe --
'cause you were on the last
2 1/2 seasons
of the mother ship.
It's been 10 years.
I can't believe
it's been 10 years.
-Yeah, it's been
a 10-year hiatus, man.
And the appetite for the show
is still there.
And that's why we're back.
So I want to thank the fans
for sticking around.
-Fantastic.
-Yeah.
-And you get to be back
in New York City.
And I would imagine that --
You know, I think that also
"Law & Order" feels like a show
that New Yorkers believe
they have an ownership stake in.
-Yeah.
-I would imagine that
when you're shooting,
because, again,
you're shooting in the streets,
you're out and about,
people must yell at you guys all
the time when you're shooting.
-All the time, man.
People try to get in the scenes
when we're working
on the street.
You know, because we can't block
off the streets in New York
like we do in L.A.
or anyplace else.
-Yeah.
-So people just walk through
the crime scene.
It's like, "Hey, man, hey!
You're destroying evidence!
Wait a minute!"
They walk through.
There's a photographer here that
works for the trades or whatnot,
man, who got into it
our very first day
of our very first episode
with the AD.
Because we're trying
to shoot a scene,
and this guy just comes in
with the camera
and starts taking pictures
as if he's a part of production.
He's just some dude -- He's just
some paparazzi dude, man.
Yeah, but it's crazy.
People yell things, ruin takes,
walk through the takes.
-Yeah, everybody
in New York City
also thinks they're the star
of their own TV show
at any given moment.
They're like,
"Oh, yeah, you got a show.
I got a show, buddy.
I got a show too."
This is very exciting.
Now, be honest.
-Yeah.
-I know you grew up out in L.A.
-Uh-huh.
-Are you a real Rams fan?
'Cause you were at
the Super Bowl, I know.
-Okay, I'm going to start off
by saying I'm a sports fan.
-Okay, we appreciate
your honesty.
-I'm a sports fan.
I grew up wanting to play
football for the Dallas Cowboys,
'cause I thought I was
going to play football.
Yeah, and then --
Because my dad's from
Little Rock, Arkansas.
That was his team.
And then I got older and I
gravitated towards the Raiders.
-Okay.
-And then I had friends
and family who played
in the league.
So I had a bunch of friends who
played for the Rams, as well.
So I've always been a Rams fan.
It's an L.A. team.
And then they moved away to
St. Louis and they came back.
So I am a Rams fan.
-So that's wonderful.
Obviously you not only
had tickets,
but there you are
with Matt Stafford.
-Yeah, on the field.
-On the field after the game.
-Yeah, right after the game,
yeah.
-A little --
A little sweatier than him.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
You know, 'cause I had to --
I had to work my way
to get down onto the field.
-Right, right.
He was just there.
-You know, he was just
effortless doing his thing.
That's why they're
the champions, man.
So, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I was shvitzing.
-There you are with OBJ.
I mean, you're with
the A-listers here.
-This is in the locker room
right after the game.
-Then with this guy right here,
Aaron Donald,
arguably as good as they come.
And that's Cedric, right?
-Cedric the Entertainer, yeah.
-That's fantastic.
And just the lack of security.
Here you guys are fully --
I mean, 'cause I was like,
there's not --
There are no Rams in this photo.
-Yeah, yeah.
No, no.
That's my best friend
Skinny Boy,
Ced the Entertainer, myself,
and the Lombardi, man.
That's how you know
you're a real fan,
when they let you
in the locker room
and hold
the championship trophy.
I'm just not no bandwagon fan.
I've been there all season.
-Yeah.
-Genuinely I'm curious.
How great is the vibe when you
are around a group of gentlemen
who have just won
the Super Bowl?
What is it like?
-Man, they were like kids
in the candy store.
You know, just -- And Ced
and my buddy Jerry and I,
we were the only civilians
in the locker room, literally.
After the whistle goes off,
they do the on-field
presentation of the trophy.
Everybody's back
in the locker room.
And it was just us, man.
And it was just crazy
seeing these champions, man,
and guys that I know,
friends of mine, you know, hoist
this trophy, smoking cigars
and having fun.
So, yeah, you can't describe it.
Words can't begin
to describe that.
-Yeah, 'cause it's that moment
where you're around
a forever thing, right?
They're just going to be
champions forever.
And what cool thing
to be around.
-Yeah, so I want to shout out
my boy O'Malley
and Stan Kroenke,
the owner of the Rams,
for giving me that access.
I appreciate you guys
and I love you.
-Very smart.
I saw what you did there.
That was very smart, 'cause
they're watching right now
like, "Why were they
in the locker room?"
-They know why I was
in the locker room.
But I just want to shout them
out on national television,
let them know that I --
Thank you. I love you guys.
-Hey, congratulations, as well.
We're talking about a new
beginning with "Law & Order."
Congratulations on "Black-ish."
What an incredible run.
What a very special show.
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And, you know, we recently --
we recently had
Tracee Ellis Ross here,
and, you know, you guys
are obviously such a --
you know,
the leads of that show,
and you play such a believable,
loving couple.
What was it like
when you guys first met?
Did you have chemistry
right away?
-Ohhh.
We had chemistry
like oil and water.
-Alright.
That's interesting.
-Yeah, we were hosting something
called the Vibe Awards
like 17 years ago.
-Oh, that's a while.
-Yeah, we were co-hosting it
together.
And it was my first time
really hanging out with Tracee.
And for the first half
of the show, we were great.
We came back
from a commercial break.
And we're walking downstage
and you hear [Revs]
And I'm with the mic.
And I just turned and said,
"Tracee, did you just fart?"
[ Laughter ]
See, you laughed.
It's funny, right?
I thought it was a funny joke.
We know she didn't fart.
We know it was that --
She hated me for 15 years.
-Yeah, well...
-She almost didn't come in
to read for the role of Rainbow
because of her disdain for me.
-Wow!
-Yeah. Yeah, but she came in.
And it was magic,
and I had no idea --
I had no idea
until the second season
that she really hated me
for all those years.
-Really?
-I had no idea.
-She waited a full season
before she came clean?
-Yeah, we were sitting there
talking and just sharing.
And she came across a picture.
I wish I had known.
I would have brought
this picture.
It was a picture of us.
And I'm happy after the show.
After the -- the award show,
the Vibe Awards show.
And I'm hugging Tracee
and I'm just cheesing.
And the look of disgust
on her face.
And she's holding my wrist like,
"Get off of me,
you disgusting man."
And she showed that picture
and she told the story.
And I was like,
"Wow, for all these years,
I thought we were friends."
-Well, now you are again,
full circle.
-Now it comes full circle.
-And "To Tell the Truth"
is back.
And one of the greatest elements
about this show --
talk about real chemistry --
your mom.
-Me and my mom.
-Your mom makes a frequent --
frequent appearances
on the show.
-We can't do the show
without my mother.
-Does your mom enjoy her time
on-camera?
-She does.
Little known fact -- My mother
always wanted to be an actor.
-Okay.
-Yeah, she's horrible.
That's why it never happened.
But she -- you know, she put her
dream of being an actor on hold
to raise an actor, not knowing
that's what she was doing.
So for me to be in the position
that I'm in today
to allow her to blossom and live
out her fantasy and her dreams
is truly a blessing.
-And I know that she's always
been intensely proud of you.
Is it true that
she used to hand out,
like, signed headshots of you?
-Used to?
-Okay.
-She still does, Seth.
-Now, are these headshots
that you have signed?
-No, Seth.
-Okay.
-Yeah, back when
there was a Kinko's,
my mother would go in and forge
my signature on a headshot
and go get a gross made.
For those of you who don't know
what a gross is,
that's thousands of pictures.
And so she would spend
all this money.
So she has boxes of forged
autographed pictures of me
in her house that she just walks
down the street --
"Anthony wanted you
to have this."
She just hands them out
to strangers still to this day.
-I can't believe that --
All you had to do
was sign one once
if she was taking them
to Kinko's.
-Yeah, no, she did it because --
She's, "Mm. Mm."
She calls me "Antny."
So she didn't even
write "Anthony."
She wrote "Antny."
"Antny Anderson."
So those are
collector's items, guys.
-If you have an original
Antny Anderson, that is --
get that on eBay today.
Hey, congratulations.
We're so happy to have you back
in New York City.
Thank you so much.
-Thanks for having me, Seth.
Pleasure.
-Anthony Anderson, everybody.
"Law & Order" returns
February 24th
at 8:00 here on NBC.